1h du mat seul le jet d'eau frémit au
bout du lac léman genève s'endort mais
aux confins de la cité une poignée
d'africains retiens la nuit
[Musique]
le parquet du calypso est incontournable
c'est le lieu de la musique africaine à
genève
son coupé décalé est impeccable sur le
dancefloor sim kool est comme un poisson
dans l'eau normal la musique et
ivoiriennes et sim kool est né à bouaké
dans le nord de la côte d'ivoire
[Musique]
vous en dix ans de vie genevois d' sim
kool à rejouer ici plus d'une fois à la
fièvre du samedi soir avec son pote
innocent ou sabine son ami coiffeuse
ce n'est pas dans mon salon parce que
[Musique]
si mme couler ses amis ivoiriens n'ont
peut-être jamais eu le coeur aussi léger
pour danser sur les rythmes du pays car
la côte d'ivoire en a fini avec une
décennie de conflit fratricide pour la
première fois en dix ans ils n'ont plus
peur pour leur famille là bas mais ils
en sont conscients en côte d'ivoire la
tranquillité n'est qu'apparente
ce qui au moins quatre mois aux produits
wassila paix
véritable
la [ __ ] et que la paix dans les arts
où que tu sois du lot du sud
la côte d'ivoire un pays qui peine
encore à croire en la paix depuis
l'investiture de son nouveau président
alassane ouattara
ouattara sort vainqueur de son combat
face à laurent gbagbo l'ancien chef de
l'état une lutte de clans qui a plongé
la côte d'ivoire dans la guerre civile
et coupé le pays en deux pendant près de
dix ans
sur fond de nationalisme les milices des
deux camps feront des milliers de morts
civils une décennie d'exactions de
violation d'accords de paix et de
xénophobie qui ont profondément marqué
les esprits
retour à genève rendez vous au salon de
sabine sabine c'est l'ami de sim kool la
coiffeuse croisés en boîte de nuit la
veille
tendance est à la hausse
depuis qu'elle s'est installée ici en
2002 elle n'a remis les pieds qu'une
fois en côte d'ivoire elle a vécu le
conflit par procuration famille au pays
et un job ici j'ai eu la peur de ma vie
hein parce que
ma soeur elle habitait juste à côté du
co militaires encore
à chaque fois qu'ils avaient les
bombardements auraient santé on suivait
france la cata chaque fois pour voir ce
qui se passe c'est pas vivre je le
souhaite à personne
chez sabine on cause de tous à une
exception près politiquement son salon
genevois reste en terrain neutre
avait la clé là je préférerais qu'on
parle pas de politique
chacun avait ses convictions et
chacun gérait comme vous voulez
lors du salon de sabine il y a bien eu
des tensions entre partisans des deux
camps mais en public le sujet est tabou
la diaspora voudrait tourner la page
[Musique]
pour tirer un trait sur ce passé récent
certains préfèrent l'action mutisme nous
retrouvons sim kool dans son bureau de
la maison de quartier du lignon en
banlieue de genève il y est agent
communal
si tu as un projet déjà tous de prendre
connaissance comme tu vois là il aura un
vide greniers le 3 septembre
donc face à sim kool désirer une
ivoirienne de 25 ans arrivé en 2005 pour
désiré impossible d'oublier le pays et
ce qu'elle y avait qu elle a créé une
association objectif récolter des fonds
pour aider les orphelins de côte
d'ivoire partie c'est quoi le nom de ton
âge je
me dis que j'en refais leno jeudi de mon
pays est parce que déjà avant d'être
unis si j'étais déplacés de guerre j'ai
vu que la guerre donc en dix mois moi
j'ai la chance de venir ici mais de
petits sont là-bas donc voila comme pas
et donne un coup de main à réaliser des
projets et à aider donner une éducation
une façon d'aider que si aujourd'hui
elle a deux grains de riz dans son
assiette n oublie pas que ya d'autres
qui n'ont rien du tout même pas
d'assiettes
si désiré a frappé à la porte de sim
kool sait qu'il vit et travaille depuis
dix ans dans le quartier et quel
quartier le lignon un paquebot de tôles
et d'acier qui héberge pas loin de sept
mille habitants de tour de 30 étages et
un immeuble le plus long d'europe qui
s'étire sur un kilomètre une hérésie
urbanistique un ghetto invivable pas du
tout plutôt une cité que tout maires de
france révèle administrés jeunes vieux
noir et blanc tout le monde semble y
cohabiter dans un calme paisible c'est
en tout cas le tableau que dresse sim
kool il est une figure du quartier il en
fait chaque jour le tour seul ou avec
ses amis ivoiriens les lignes on a plus
de 40 ans aujourd'hui mais c'est le
paradis
c'est un quartier qui bouge
et l'idée même que rooney tout de suite
en ville et tout de suite à la campagne
ça j'adore
dans les faits le quartier a parfois
mauvaise réputation auprès des jeunes
voix mais le lignon reste un symbole de
la mixité culturelle de genève
[Musique]
quand j'ai quitté l'afrique j'ai dit mon
pays et j'ai dit comme ça mon petit
frère mon pays de rêve c'est genève
après s'est moqué de moi il dit
bungert arrivé en suisse à genève ça
fait environ dix ans et je sais pas pour
moi c'est la ville genève c'est la vida
parce qu on y trouve tout le monde cette
cosmopolite au coeur d'une suis souvent
jugées conservatrices genève fait figure
de petit new york une ville monde ou
plutôt un village monde planté au bout
d'une mer intérieure y accostent toutes
les nationalités et y débarque toutes
les saveurs à deux pas du salon de
coiffure de sa mine il y à l'épicier sri
lankais idéal pour préparer la cuisine
du monde sabine y trouve tous les
ingrédients de ses recettes africaine
l'arachide pour le mafé le poisson pour
l'attaqué
en afrique c'est moins cher par rapport
à ici
l'invention on a envie de manger
africain n'a obligé de
passer par la question
ce soir sabine reçoit ses amis à la
maison en cuisine ces opérations dîner
presque parfait à l'ivoirienne avec son
amie marie france pilier du salon de
coiffure
marie france elle à l'ivoirienne la
mieux coiffés du monde africain
actuellement sur le marché
les amis de sabine sont à l'image des
quatre mille ivoiriens de la diaspora
genevoise qu'ils soient issus du nord ou
du sud qu'ils soient enfants de
diplomates ou de familles modestes tous
ont un point commun ils ont moins de 40
ans et ont fui une interminable crise
politique
il ya dans la communauté aussi ici
j'aime ma ville des gens qui sont pro
gbagbo puis des gens qui étaient pro
ouattara fait ça est ce que je sais pas
que les choses qui ont miné la
communauté qui pourraient des problèmes
c'est quelque chose que vous vous êtes
capable de surmonter et finalement
devoir pouvait être
jusqu'à quel point tu vas faire amener
quelqu'un jusqu'à quel point la
politique pouvait diviser ou rassembler
doigt celles pour moi c'est là qu'on ne
vais pas arriver on ne pète pas su mener
jusqu'à ce jusqu'à ce point on a un seul
pays
sabine et ses amis ont des passés
ensemble les divisions du pays pour tous
une chose est sûre bien au chaud dans
leur cocon helvètes ne retourneront pas
en côte d'ivoire sans l'assurance d'une
paix solide et porteuse d'avenir
[Musique]